is the counselor to the president Kelly
and Conway Kelly and welcome aboard hi
Sean by the way can you please tell the
audience what kind of shoes you're
wearing tonight they really want to know
I wouldn't dare because I don't engage
in such petty nonsense yeah and by the
way so I just came up on my radio show
today because my my staff would say what
shoes do you wear I didn't know I had a
hold of my shoe until today
I didn't know does anybody this is how
petty this isn't funny when people are
dying everything they weren't the whole
lives for is being destroyed that's
right and this is seriously what they
want to talk about this is not why he's
one bag drop the other back jobless
North Korea brazenly launching a missile
towards Japan invading their sovereignty
and obviously violating just general
conventions of international standards
but but look your opening segment is
very instructive you basically asked the
question Shawn when will the Trump
detractors naysayers and critics
particularly those in the media when
will it end the question is when will it
actually matter there's very little
indication that what the media are
telling the Americans is important to
them is actually important to them we
saw that on the campaign and we see an
out in his presidency he does not let
them stop him from pushing forward on
his agenda today is exhibit a of that he
went to Missouri he went to the heart of
route 66 the mainland main the main Main
Street America and basically said to
them we want these manufacturing jobs to
come back
you deserve a pay raise you deserve a
tax cut the instruction page for the
simple form is over 240 pages long
that's the instruction page we're
spending billions of hours
we're costing millions of jobs and
trillions of dollars because of this
draconian outdated a tax code and by the
way the tax code currently favors the
rich it correct it currently favors
those could afford lobbyists lawyers
accountants to help them figure out how
to pay little to no taxes so he went to
Missouri today anyway to tell the nation
and to tell the Congress by the way when
they get back next week that this
president is set on reforming tax the
tax code and giving relief to
middle-class families number one number
two he went to Texas yesterday
the Vice President is going tomorrow and
the president will be back there and
possibly Louisiana on Saturday he's not
going to allow the people in the peanut
gallery who should be spending their
time connecting people with information
tell them how to get diapers pet rescue
food medical supplies medical care look
at what our cabinet members are doing
they're there with the president the
vice president instructing folks as to
where they can get much-needed help and
you've got the media obsesses trying to
tear down the president I just think
it's not going to work
let me put up another favorable opinion
that came out at what 44% Pence's 46%
Paul Ryan Paul Ryan got some things done
in the house good for him more than
they've done in the Senate then you look
at Nancy Pelosi 31% Schumer 27% Mitch
McConnell 20% and 18% in his own State
I'm hoping they're paying attention that
the president remains twice as popular
because he's doing his job and keeping
his promises and I think Congress needs
to you know get on board finally well
these are dated which were very much
aware in the White House particularly
why don't you throw of the mainstream
media numbers as well somebody can call
me and let me know when the president's
approval rating gets as low as the
media's approval rating and the
Congress's and the parties I mean this
is an incredibly important point because
people see that he's trying to make good
on his promises he believes it's a moral
imperative to get health care reform
done to get tax relief to middle-class
families and he is urging Congress he
said today he's urging Congress to
revive themselves and rescue themselves
by passing taxi form and that's really
the president reminding them that they
stood in the way of him pen in hand
signing into law health care reform you
got 29 million Americans without health
insurance right now you have 20 million
who opted out of Obama care 6.5 million
who paid a penalty Sean because they
didn't want this great thing called
Obama care why is that important it's
important because you have a president
who remains committed to getting it done
we're working with the governors we're
looking at the gramm cassidy bill we're
looking for alternatives and
this is a president ready to work with
the Congress but they need to come to
the table too and get serious and again
our thoughts and prayers are with
everyone affected Harvey recovery and
rebuilding will take a very long time we
were acutely aware of that
all right Kelly maybe next time I'll see
you have a new pair of shoes considering
the country so obsessed on the Left
which shoes thank you very very right
now we don't have to talk about
unbelievable
all right thank you so much